hey guys it is the 31st of mate way my
name is just and here's what's happening
in video games French gaming websites
game blog dot F R has reported the
sequel to injustice gods among us is in
the works for ps4 xbox one and prestige
citing sources familiar with the project
the website is claiming that the sequel
will be announced soon and is headed for
a March 27 release as yet neither
develop another realm nor warner
brothers interactive have hinted at
plans for injustice gods among us to
injustice is a fighting game featuring
characters from the DC Comics universe
and stars characters like Superman
Batman and Wonder Woman among many
others the first game lost in April of
2013 for xbox 360 ps3 and pc an ultimate
edition was also later released on ps4
and Xbox one Capcom has revealed that an
updated version of resident evil 5 will
arrive on xbox one and ps4 on jun 28 the
rear release is set to feature an
improved frame rate and 1080p resolution
as well as all previously released VLC
also included is the mercenaries United
mode which is the series of timed arcade
shooter experience featuring additional
characters and stages and the more
difficult version of mercenaries called
no mercy which featured in the PC
release will also be a part of the
console re-release in February of this
year Capcom revealed their plans to
re-release Rosie four five and six on
ps4 and Xbox one the rear release of
Resident Evil 6 came out in March of
this year finally granturismo sport is
going to be missing out on a few of the
key features from the earlier games when
it releases on ps4 series creator
Kazunori Yamauchi told gtplanet about
the new game will not include dynamic
time or
he explains we opted to not have the
transitions in the race this time in
order to raise the frame rate and the
quality of the image during the race so
the user will be able to set that before
they enter the race so you'll still be
able to have no traces morning breezes
at dawn dusk and so on that said the
game will have a damaged system the lack
of which has been a sticking point in
park and yamauchi confirmed they are
targeting 1080p and 60 frames per second
granturismo sport will include more than
130 cars and support for online and
offline play let me know down in that
comment section how you feel about the
missing features from grants women
squirt be sure the head to gain spot
where we've got stories on Rainbow six
siege and an xbox one price drop that's
everything I've got for you today as
always do let me know what mattered to
you and I will see you again tomorrow